leur gagner c'est vraiment comme un chef
d'orchestre c'est comme si c'est lui qui
décide quels instruments tisse ses doit
jouer c'est comme si les banques et wall
violon tu joues donc moi je suis ici je
décide bons mets toi le bourdon vite tu
joues au hockey at il ajouté accompagné
avec le bourdon 16
puis maintenant je vais voir m c'est là
que je vous parlais de couleur c'est que
l'on changé comme l enveloppe sonore le
thème général de cette note le décalage
voire ajouté
une autre tonalité
non
on perçoit très bien que c'est bien sous
ses traits différents sauts de joie
il donnait de la richesse la couleur un
peu comme le peintre avec sa palette qui
dit bon mais je remette un peu plus de
rougemont bleu puis était un peu plus de
gens donc je vais aller chercher je
conseille chercher déploie
plus à l'est varicent et plus vous
rajoutez des tuyaux enfin plus je veux
aller chercher découdra de la brillance
d'armissan
je me ramasse avec un espèce de son
composite donc plusieurs tuyaux qui
parlent en même temps qu'ils peuvent
même parfois s'apparenter com créé le
mélange c'est harmonix et son différent
là vous me donnez kezman imitation dans
une autre instrument